what do you eat when no one else is
there to see you that's just a solo
version of what you do when others are
around with one setting instead of two
or more but we know that's luxury we
know how much weirder you get yet it's a
lonely guilty knowledge cookery pages
keep on pushing a different vision of
what we like smart but casual rustling
up well organized carefully nutritious
meals for one but that's not normal at
all as we come into real nuts in part
due to insights afforded us by social
media and never-ending stream dimly-lit
junk food concoctions this is what we
really like it's normal indeed pretty
much universal to do odd things so in
truth they're not really odd at all
alone we coat fish fingers with
mayonnaise we try pasta with marmalade
the perfect meal might be three chicken
drumsticks and a chocolate bar and
nothing else we know this about
ourselves and yet we continue to lie to
others you invite friends over to eat
you worry and fuss and create elaborate
recipes but in truth they too might just
fancy a cheese sandwich in the packet of
crisps out for dinner a smart restaurant
you might secretly crave can chicken
soup serve with fries or a baguette full
of peas but deference to the idea of
what's normal
prevents you from speaking up
we're gradually coming to realize in a
great many fields that it's normal to be
abnormal take art in the first off the
19th century the English painter JMW
Turner worked for his own pleasure on
painting she never exhibited publicly or
even showed to anyone during his
lifetime
they're like sausages covered in sugar
to make money and earn himself a
reputation he had to make more standard
things nowadays we recognize how much
greater the private Turner was and a
less prestigious the still very
important way our secret eating styles
are like Turner's hidden pictures in so
many areas of life twisting on a journey
of discovery shyly daring to own up to
our true selves